Anything can go wrong on live news.
The hardest part of the job for those brave
souls who sit in the anchor's chair is remaining
calm and collected no matter what happens.
For the most part, they do an admirable job.
But occasionally their emotions get the best
of them.
When that happens, the results are incredible.
Here are some of the funniest flip-outs from
our favorite anchors and hosts.
F-Bombs Away
After reporting on a story about a medical
marijuana business in Alaska, KTVA reporter
Charlo Greene resigned on the air.
"Now everything you heard is why I, the actual
owner of the Alaska Cannabis Club, will be
dedicating all of my energy toward fighting
for freedom and fairness, which begins with
legalizing marijuana here in Alaska.
And as for this job…
Well, not that I have a choice, but f--- it.
I quit."
"Alright we apologize for that…"
Greene later admitted that her live spectacle
was a ruse to increase public support of medical
marijuana.
Nothing changes conservative voters' minds
like erratic behavior in connection with drug
use, right?
John Brown vs. the Kardashians
A lot of people dislike the Kardashians, but
John Brown, one of the anchors of Good Morning
Orlando, took it to a new level.
He literally walked off the set in protest
of a story about them.
He couldn't help screaming his disapproval
from off camera as his co-host tried to quickly
get through the segment.
"Okay, I'm having a good Friday, so I refuse
to talk about the Kardashians today.
You are on your own Amy."
"You left me!"
"I had enough Kardashians.
I can't take anymore Kardashian stories on
this show."
He was quickly replaced by another co-host,
but couldn’t stop yelling.
"It's a non-story.
It's a non-story!"
Unfortunately, he'd just made the entire thing
into a story bigger than Kylie Jenner’s
lips.
Anchors miss bridge implosion
"A bridge is about to be imploded this morning
to make room for a new bridge."
A routine bridge implosion was the epic event
two WGN Chicago anchors were banking on to
be the highlight of their broadcast.
After waiting for several minutes for it to
happen, they briefly cut away to the weather
guy.
Of course, this is exactly when the bridge
fell.
"Are you kidding me?"
It was played for laughs, but it was obvious
they were disappointed.
"I'm like an angry troll.
Man, we really were going to knock it out
of the park."
WE'LL DO IT LIVE!
Before he screamed at people for all kinds
of reasons on The O'Reilly Factor, Bill O'Reilly
screamed at the crew of Inside Edition.
His freakout was for one very specific infraction:
the teleprompter.
During one of the most amazingly awkward clips
in internet history, O'Reilly is clearly running
late for something.
The teleprompter screws up multiple times,
uncorking the host's full fury.
"I can't do it.
We'll do it live."
"Okay."
"No wait..."
"We'll do it live, f--- it!
Do it live!
I'll write it, and we'll do it live!
F---ing thing sucks."
To his credit, O'Reilly is still able to snap
right into congenial host mode when he has
to.
Which makes him either a consummate media
professional or a frightening sociopath.
Either way, the clip is a classic.
Jim Ryan vs. Dick Oliver
It’s a live interview that features a building
manager and tenant giving their sides of a
contentious construction project.
You'd expect one of the interviewees to be
at the highest risk of a freakout.
But in this clip from Good Day New York, it's
actually the anchor, Jim Ryan, who tears into
chief reporter Dick Oliver.
"Right, so what do you want now?"
"Well, if I have to teach you how to be a
reporter, Olly, I'll do that later."
"Is there any question you'd like me to ask
her?"
"No, I'll give you lessons on how to become
a reporter later."
"No, I'll give you lessons on how to be an
editor, because I was your boss once"
"Yeah you were, and are no longer, how did
that happen?"
It's an amazing peek into the dynamic of a
television newsroom.
And aging media personalities.
Piers Morgan politely flips
In a prolonged debate with two gun rights
advocates, Piers Morgan desperately tries
to get a single person to agree with any recently
proposed gun control measures.
Morgan fails miserably, so what does he do?
He gently crumples up his notes and tosses
them aside.
He very nearly raises his voice as well.
Morgan reserved his true bile for other gun
rights interviews, however.
"I know why sales of these weapons have been
soaring in the last few days, it's down to
idiots like you."
There's also a possibility that he later,
in a clear sign of extreme displeasure, served
them tea with no crumpets whatsoever.
Whoopi Goldberg & Joy Behar walk off
Yep, Bill O'Reilly made this list twice.
Only this time, he's the one who keeps his
cool while Whoopi Goldberg and Joy Behar walk
offstage after O’Reilly’s remarks about
9/11.
"Muslims kill us on 9/11."
To their credit, they both came back after
O'Reilly clarified his statements.
It was still an epic meltdown moment for a
show whose entire formula is built on people
arguing for an hour… with the occasional
cooking segment thrown in.
Bill Maher gets hands-on
On Real Time with Bill Maher, Bill's job as
host is to discuss the highly contentious
political topics of the day.
So, it's never a surprise when emotions run
high.
For the most part, debates take place among
the panel guests.
"It's not a debate.
It's a debate between us.
You're in the audience.
Audience comes from the Latin, 'to listen.'"
But on one show, protesters from the audience
were so disruptive, Bill had to intervene.
"Hey do we have some f---ing security in this
building?
Or do I have to come over and kick this guy's
a-- out of here?
Hey, could you get the f--- out of my building?
Hey.
Out.
Out!"
Some time later, Maher was heckled again,
but at least Kevin Smith took responsibility
for the disruption.
"Dad, shut up!"
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
freakout you think should've made the list...